Jeff D'Andria: Just looking for some thoughts out there.
Jeff D'Andria: Yep, Sean.
Shawn Lin: So for the highlights…
Shawn Lin: How many bullet points would you recommend? Because, like.
Shawn Lin: You currently have 5 on there, right? Yeah.
Shawn Lin: I remember, well, I took CTI, the accelerated course, they recommended 3. Is that still the standard, or do you… would you like more or less than that?
Jeff D'Andria: Love it. Great question. Because I…
Jeff D'Andria: I mean, I put that thing together, and then I put this thing together, so why am I… am I, like, flip-flopping? I think it really depends on you, depends on the role,
Jeff D'Andria: I think it's kind of… When the song changes, the dance changes.
Jeff D'Andria: I think, in this layout, 3 looks clean.
Jeff D'Andria: I could see, maybe, you're right, maybe 5 starting to feel potentially a little crowded, depending on your content.
Jeff D'Andria: So maybe it's, like, Maybe it's like this, you know?
Jeff D'Andria: Maybe it's like that?
Jeff D'Andria: But I think it really is, like, it depends, I think is the answer, but if you needed an answer.
Jeff D'Andria: Perhaps, like, 3 or 4 might look cleaner?
Jeff D'Andria: I think this is the one I really would wish for you all.
Jeff D'Andria: is… If there's one way to… my resume's solid.
Jeff D'Andria: But is there a way I could still customize a resume without having to customize, like, a whole page resume, right? I did so much work on it. But man, what if you could just do, like, at least one sentence on the resume that shows… this person did not send this to a bunch of other companies, because this bullet is completely aligned to me.
Jeff D'Andria: Like, to my team, at my company.
Jeff D'Andria: That's… you know, I'd wish that for y'all.
Jeff D'Andria: And it's a nice way to feel like you're customizing for each company if you really, you know.
Jeff D'Andria: If you… if you want to show up in the most competitive way.
Sathya Narayanan: If I could add, like, kind of two points to that, which are somewhat related, but… no, actually not. Like, they are helpful, I think. One is, so there is some psychology research around, like, kind of three short
Sathya Narayanan: points is what our brain is capable of understanding, human brain is capable of understanding. So if we can make three, kind of, it's kind of like a boom, boom, it has to be boom, like, kind of, I don't know, boom, boom, boom, right? Like, kind of, it needs to be…
Sathya Narayanan: like, some quality and evidence, quality and evidence, quality and evidence, right? Some quality I have, and here is the evidence for it. Like, kind of, if you can make it like that, I think it's helpful.
Sathya Narayanan: But the other thing I would say, like, what Jeff said in terms of it depends.
Sathya Narayanan: the other side of it that I want everybody to understand is, like, it really does depend, and you need to be experimenting. So the next phase of career intelligence, we are going to talk about, like, kind of, own your search is the next phase, like, starting next week. And what we mean by that is.
Sathya Narayanan: The one rule is there are no rules.
Sathya Narayanan: Right? You need to kind of really experiment with
Sathya Narayanan: variations. Even if you picked 3 highlights, you want to try 3 different 3 highlights. Maybe you want to try a four-highlight resume, too. So there is an amount of experimentation you need to do in a structured way, not in a random, like, just keep changing stuff and sending it away, and we are going to talk about it in the next part of the workshop.
Sathya Narayanan: So that is really important. There is no one solution that is going to work for anybody, for any job.
Sathya Narayanan: But it's not that you have to rewrite the entire resume, but some amount of experimentation on the edges needs to be our mindset, right? It's kind of like an entrepreneurial mindset in your job search, where you are testing it with different customers, and you need to kind of learn from it. So I'd encourage keeping that in mind, yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: Something from the conversation with our… our…
Jeff D'Andria: Ashby Contact, and looking at thousands of employers, so they're, they're… they're, they're… what they say was just, like, so… coming from data. One thing they said was, and this could be for the highlights,
Jeff D'Andria: He's like.
Jeff D'Andria: if… if this is, like, something that you love, like, if you kind of, like… what do you love? But if you love the kind of problems we're working on, we'd love to know that, right? So, if we're doing… as you're doing the niche work, hopefully we're getting more towards stuff that you're really into.
Jeff D'Andria: maybe you use the word love? But they need to… we need… we gotta, like.
Jeff D'Andria: Capture that, like, lightning in a bottle of you, like, what is it about this?
Jeff D'Andria: Because they need to know that you're really into this stuff.
Jeff D'Andria: And maybe you can glean that from the kind of problems you've worked on, but why not just be explicit, own the narrative, and maybe that's where you put that.
Jeff D'Andria: In a sentence like this. They need to know that you're really into it, and that's a… that's a competitive stance. That… that helps you go from the 500 applicants to… wait, there's, like, there's, like, you know, 10 or less that actually showed they, like, really love this stuff.
Jeff D'Andria: So, that, that stood out to me. So,
Jeff D'Andria: Before we start crafting our own versions of this, which is… is what I have up here, directions and all, we'll partner up. Anything…
Jeff D'Andria: else about, kind of, the one… the one-third idea.
Sathya Narayanan: Looks like Adrian has a question. Jeff, I don't know if you saw that there's a hand up, yeah.
Adrian Vo: Hi, Jeff. I have, like, two quick questions, if that's okay. Yeah. So, my first one is…
Adrian Vo: How important is, like, the ordering of, like, the sections? I see, like, on the tech resume.
Adrian Vo: the technical skills come first, and then projects and the work experience, but let's say I have more work experience than projects, like.
Jeff D'Andria: Hmm.
Adrian Vo: Like, does the order of it really matter?
Jeff D'Andria: Sorry, yeah, great question, and I know with our limited time, I didn't choose to go super, big on the resume in general, but this is a great kind of question on that.
Jeff D'Andria: Zooming out beyond the highlights. So this is… I'd say this resume is kind of more designed
Jeff D'Andria: There's no rules, so we can move things around. More designed, probably, for someone that, like, hasn't had
Jeff D'Andria: super relevant job experience yet, so we kind of need to prioritize, like, projects, like, that's their most relevant, competitive thing, and let's, you know, put that as close to the top as possible. But Adrian, if you have
Jeff D'Andria: a job, or an internship, or a something, that's probably gonna be better than, you know, projects, like, say, from class or something. Hell yeah, put that… put that way up higher.
Jeff D'Andria: I would say…
Jeff D'Andria: An even better word, like, we have down here on the second page. Like, technical experience?
Jeff D'Andria: is probably…
Jeff D'Andria: I might even end up just swapping that out soon. Technical experience is going to be better than work experience.
Jeff D'Andria: Again, this is probably for someone that doesn't have technical experience yet, because they haven't had an internship.
Jeff D'Andria: Okay, we're trying to…
Jeff D'Andria: not make the recruiter infer or fish, because, like, sometimes I've seen resumes where they actually have, very relevant software, say, experience, for computer science folks, but they still call it work experience.
Jeff D'Andria: you're making me work as a reader. Like, if it just said software experience or technical, like, you're just priming my brain, you're trending me toward a yes.
Jeff D'Andria: But work experience, you're betting on me having enough calories and energy to kind of infer further, you know? And that's this thing with the highlights, like, I don't want to make them fish, I just want to, like, give them the best, you know?
Adrian Vo: Okay, yeah, that makes sense.
Adrian Vo: And also, that kind of leads me into my second question.
Adrian Vo: Like, how, I guess, should I kind of be weighing how much emphasis I put into the highlights? So, like, if, let's say, like, I want to prioritize putting more into, like, projects and, like, work experience, like, is it better to just shorten the highlights, or is it, like, very crucial to have, like.
Adrian Vo: Like, a good amount of highlights to,
Adrian Vo: I guess, like, is it, like, really, really important to have, like, a strong, like, highlight section?
Jeff D'Andria: I'd say the highlights is an option. I know so much of today is about it, but I wanted to give it, like, the biggest, like, generalizable thing that I think would work for a lot of people. I don't think a highlights section is a requirement at all, yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: Particularly if your other sections just stand up so tall, and it's like…
Jeff D'Andria: you know, I'd have to look at your resume to give my personal take, but yeah, sometimes…
Jeff D'Andria: I'll be honest, I don't… like, the highlights isn't something that I think people use a lot, and it's kind of the reason I'm recommending it, because we need to break the pattern. We need to fit the pattern, and then break it. And I think…
Jeff D'Andria: This just shows that you're putting extra, like, the effort in to make it…
Jeff D'Andria: to articulate the best about you, and that's, like, that all goes a long way. But you don't have to have one, that's for sure.
Adrian Vo: Okay, thank you.
Jeff D'Andria: It's a good thing to try, though, I think, if you're not getting hits.
Jeff D'Andria: yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: Particularly also if you just have these, like, great experiences, but they're super, like, buried, say, like.
Jeff D'Andria: Like, maybe I was…
Jeff D'Andria: I was, like, a Walm… I worked at Walmart as a tell… like, at the front, whatever, checking people out. But I did, like, a little piece for a couple weeks that was, like, a total software thing that felt like an internship, but my title was…
Jeff D'Andria: associate, and I was just stocking shelves.
Jeff D'Andria: But, like, I'm afraid they're not gonna see that, because they're just gonna see Walmart stocked shelves, but I could tease out the little two weeks of software that I did, because I went above and beyond, and, like, stretched. I'm gonna throw that in the highlights, because I'm afraid they'll never read it. You know what I mean? So highlights is a way to tease out some of these just best experiences.